okay so I am groots he's the titular
character Branch out into his own
animated series said in the MCU it's
spelled with some cool cameos and little
Easter eggs that we're gonna be breaking
down throughout this video if you don't
want any spoilers then I suggest you
leave the video and also don't forget to
hit the Thumbs Up Button if you enjoy
some bad puns spoken in a limey British
accent about the way a huge thank you
for clicking this now let's get into I
am Groot now each episode begins with
group fast forwarding his way through
the classic Marvel Studios Fanfare I
respect that Disney heard our complaints
about their shows having 10 minutes of
credits and they cut them down to reveal
the true length of each entry I'm just
kidding but the first episode is called
hot spring bird this shares the name
with the 2017 iron group comic about the
character being stuck on a planet called
terminal I'm guessing this is the
tropical one that we join the character
on but the source material did have him
away from the Guardians however here we
catch the Benatar perched on a hill the
art style of the comic fully pulls
across to the new series and the log go
in text at the end look similar to how
it's presented in the source material
now it was said that this series would
take place between the ending of
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2's final
scene and its post credits one this was
confirmed by the creative team though
the second entry clearly takes place
right after the first movie anyway the
first entry follows the little guy as he
finds a hot spring inside a puddle the
mud of which gets mixed with a flying
insect and also some fruit it's very
much A Little Spa for him and he even
done some cucumbers on the eyes like
your uncle Kevin's spoilers when he gets
a day away from the kids this lets him
grow his leaves rapidly and he ends up
styling it in a sort of getting dressed
Montage that was a staple of 80s movies
and also Wonder Woman 1 and Wonder Woman
1984 there was there wasn't anything in
between those no the guy transforms into
a Chia Pet then into a center a poodle
dolphin and an 18th century lady oh I'm
a lady guessing guessing most of the
people watching this are under 10 so you
probably don't get that reference and I
also think that little Brayden is
probably canceled now so just cut that
bit cut it either way Groot takes the
fear from a multi-colored animal and he
wears it as a scarf cementing this as
being the best body ever next we cut the
bonsai tree which as mentioned earlier
seems to pick up right after the end of
Guardians of the Galaxy that had him
dancing to I Want You Back by The
Jackson 5 and here he watches he grows
from a twig into his baby Persona now
the ship is filled with references to
other films and beside him we can catch
a little fruit this is the same one that
nebula was constantly trying to get to
in the second film and upon biting it
she discovered it wasn't ripe
[Music]
is not right
it's not ripe now he's watering grown by
two torture probe looking droids but
it's all good as he gets to eat some
cheese puffs in his little pot Guardians
2 had a meeting junk food at certain
points so it's nice that he developed
his diet of garbage early on in his life
after he cracks the part he shifted over
to the other side of the room and behind
him we can catch the cassette deck that
Peter popped the awesome mix Vol 2 and
2. the tape looks exactly the same to
how it did in that movie but Peter or
wait until you hear about LimeWire baby
[Music]
is replaced by the bonsai tree and the
word Bonsai actually translates
literally to mean Tree in a pot as he
swings we hear the song Blue to new
playing and this was featured in 2001 A
Space Odyssey Junior low gravity scenes
they also have a riff that sounds very
similar to the main theme of that movie
laughs
[Music]
this piece by Richard Strauss was titled
sunrise and it helped to cement the
message of Humanity's Evolution from
crawling out the dirt which Groot
literally does he takes his first few
steps says I am Groot and also makes
peace with his fallen tree brother
whilst he eats some cheese puffs next we
cut to short number three which is
titled dancing Groot wakes up on the
ravaged ship which I believe is called
the eclecter this belonged to the gang
and it was stolen by rocket yondu
angrude during the second movie he ends
up coming across a box of smart watches
and using one of these as a headlight he
finds a mysterious vial that's been
broken open as he walks through the dark
Corridor there's lots of Vibes about
alien and Aliens the latter of which was
directed by James Cameron I feel like
Cameron gets another nod in this entry
when Groot finally comes across the
creature that escaped not only does it
move in shape-shift like the T-1000 but
it's also very similar to water
creatures in the abyss and how they move
and change shapes love that they pay
homage to some of the first major CGI
effects and this series shows how far
animation has come Groot reads a book on
the toilet and on this we can see Thanos
as well as some little white fluffy
aliens these are known as values and
they too appeared in Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 2. one also shows up at the
beginning of the fifth short when it
attacks The Treehouse that group builds
he searches for the creature in a
Russian doll and he also jumps on a
purple banana which two appeared on the
cover of the book James Gunn is also
credited as leading his voice to the
wristwatch you have walked 300 steps
now there's one thing that Groot learned
from Peter at the end of Guardians it's
that sometimes you've gotta have a
dance-off bro just as he burst stood out
the moves on Ronin here group goes
against the creature in a scene that
feels very reminiscent of Shadow Mario
the Pergo face to face to ran cancan by
Tito Puente and group blasts him out the
airlock this again is probably
referencing aliens namely how Ripley
took the queen out in that film which is
a nice way to tie the whole thing
together Curt to episode 4 and we catch
Groot walking down a corridor whilst the
song you can get it if you really want
place in the background we see he has a
JanSport backpack and this has a NASA
badge on it as well as the ghost from
Pac-Man the backpack itself actually
belonged to Peter and this is what he
was wearing at the start of Guardians of
the Galaxy when he was picked up by
yondu now this is filled with lots of
references to Earth and the 80s
including an Alf Comic Standing for
alien life form this sitcom followed an
alien that crash landed on Earth and
lived with a family it was satirized in
the recent note movie and the monkey in
that was called Gordy with alf's true
name also being Gordon you probably
haven't seen that as like I said year 10
unless you're actually 30 in which case
what are you watching I am group for
what do you mean I'm watching it as well
now we follow Groot in a scene that's
sort of similar to the one in the second
film where he steals all kinds of items
from the ravager crew he cuts off some
of Rocket's fur which he later uses on a
family picture and he also steals some
sub from Drax Ali I think it's tracks
couldn't see anyone there because
whoever it was was moving so slowly that
they were almost invisible now he also
grabbed some annulax batteries which
appeared at the start of Guardians 2
along with these arbilary batteries we
also see the cheese pup packet from the
bonsai tree episode and next to it is
the crack plan pot that also showed up
in that using the elf cover he creates a
canvas and he cooks this with a rocket
boot this belonged to Star-Lord and it's
something that he used to fly around
with during the end of the second film
in a further tie back to that we see
gruders learned how to press the big red
button which he had trouble with in the
bomb scene from that movie he blows a
hole in the ship and then we get an
appearance by rocket he wears some
little eyeglasses that I don't think
we've seen him put on before and almost
gets sucked out he's pretty annoyed but
his Timber quickly dies down after he
sees the picture has the family on
including Gamora who looks a bit like
She-Hulk there's also Peter who has his
Walkman and it's a nice little family
drawing anyway for the final episode
we're going over to Jared for his um
amazing amazing Easter eggs
[Music]
so this episode's it's it's a bit
it's a bit like Gulliver's Travels
isn't it I I can't believe I'm getting
paid for this
was that it was was that all you had
[Music]
anyway we follow grid as he makes a
treehouse for himself but this is
brought down by a bylos which we see in
the opening shot sitting on a tree
branch this is taken out by a bird which
leads to Groot discovering some tiny
life bombs under a rock the musical
stings here also once more mimic 2001 A
Space Odyssey
[Music]
there are also flashes of Hall of the
Mountain King as well or as I call it
the Alton Towers theme tune
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Vibes as we watch The Little People
feasting on it they look so happy
including this old woman who cries who
crushed good steps on them as he races
back with some leaves however they're
all good baby and that ends the episode
so yeah some nice little Easter eggs in
there that would watch this again if I'm
being honest but it's one for the kids
and I know it's something I can put on
TV and just let my two little Lads watch
on Loop whilst I make my fifth video of
the day it's what a true father would do
and I hope you enjoy this breakdown I
think the animation was great and though
the series was pretty much all filler I
get that I'm not really the target
audience and there's probably people out
there who have fun with this a lot more
than I did no so I'm not gonna hate on
it I'm just gonna say it's not for me
now let me know your thoughts on it
below it obviously the animations good
as well and there will be people who
like that which really happy for you I
thought was okay if I'm gonna score it
six out of ten anyway let me know your
thoughts on it below and if you're
following the channel we're almost at
the end of our competition time for the
month we're giving away three copies of
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness on the 15th of August and all
you have to do depend on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the series we pick the comments at
random on the 15th and the winners of
the last one on screen right now so
that's you message me on Twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of Westworld I know you
kids you love Westworld as well uh so
yeah head over there right after this if
not thanks for sticking through the
video I've been bored and I'll see you
next time take care peace